you can't miss this an adorable and
exhausted little boy from toronto named
carter trozoa i hope i said that right
is getting all the love from one of the
biggest names in hollywood yeah carter
went viral this past winter after ctv
news cameras caught him hard at work
shoveling snow but
he wasn't exactly thrilled to be doing
it
yeah and i think it's safe to say it was
all worth it in the end after he caught
the attention of kelly clarkson and paid
a virtual visit to the kelly clarkson
show take a look and we'll see you guys
next time
if you didn't have a machine to help you
move the snow you probably found it a
bit
tiring
[Music]
a snow day turned into a work day for
carter trazolo i really wish i was in
school right now
trisolo was clearing snow around not
just his house but also doing it for my
neighbors friends
probably people i even don't know
what's up carter
hi
oh my gosh i wish you were here i want
to hug you so hard you're so cute so
carter how happy are you that the snow
season is over
i'm pretty happy guys shoveling the snow
was
really exhausting
i love you so the snow was really bad
that day though right that was deep
yeah it's the biggest snowstorm i've
seen in toronto
um
i was at the store i was pretty happy
that a school day was canceled
and
but after a little while i got bored so
i asked my mom what should i do and my
mom said i should go and shovel outside
because i've been doing it for a couple
of years to help the community
and so i did maybe an hour half later
i
um i'm finishing up and a news reporter
comes up to me and starts asking me
questions and by then i was extremely
exhausted so why why do you think people
loved your videos so much and what's
happened since then uh i think they
liked it because we're all exhausted
from either coved work isolation or
other things that i have no idea about
and i don't
and i know how they feel because i am
always exhausted